[موسيقى] [موسيقى]
أجنبية
، فهذه سيارات ذاتية القيادة ،
فهذا يعني أننا نستخدم كاميرات رادار ليدار
لإدراك ما يحيط بنا من أن
المعلومات تأتي إلى كمبيوتر مركزي
وهناك برنامج أساسي على
هذا الكمبيوتر كتبه
فريق الجامعة يخبر السيارة  ما يجب القيام به
لا يوجد عجلة قيادة لا يوجد
إنسان يتحكم في السيارة يجب أن
يقودها بنفسها تمامًا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
حتى ترى ورائي
هناك نافذة على غطاء
المحرك تحتها
تسمى  كمبيوتر مدمج في السيارة ،
ما هو إلى حد كبير هو
جهاز كمبيوتر مكتبي يعمل بكامل طاقته ، لذا فهو يعمل بنظام
Windows في الوقت الحالي وأي
شيء يمكنك القيام به
بجهاز الكمبيوتر في المنزل يمكنك القيام به في هذه
السيارة ، ولكن أثناء التنقل ، يوجد اتصال 5G مدمج ،
لذلك لديك  أنت تعلم أنه
يمكنك ممارسة الألعاب أثناء التنقل إذا كنت أه
يمكنك تبديل البث في السيارة
نظرًا للداخل في كاميرات السيارة
[الموسيقى]
فأنت تأخذ مدخلات التصميم
ومتطلباتك  ضعهم في
الجهاز وكان أكبر
ثورة من الناحية التكنولوجية على مدار
نصف القرن الماضي هي قوة الحوسبة
، ثم يأخذ الجهاز كل تلك البيانات
ويخلق حرفيًا بنية مثالية